of the most fascinating and striking
kinds of talismanic objects is the
magical healing Bowl these were used for
specific purposes to help with a
particular therapeutic or physical
problem and is a practice that goes back
to a similar bowls used in earlier
Aramaic speaking contexts the difference
with the bowls in the Islamic context is
that they are most usually made of metal
and almost exclusively again invokes God
just like most Islamic Magic and let me
tell you some of these objects are just
absolutely amazing look at this bowl it
has everything it has depictions of
these symbolic animals described earlier
it has magic squares the Seal of Solomon
is there versus from the Quran it's just
absolutely magnificent to some